[MUSIC PLAYING]
SOUVIK CHOUDHURY: So
the topic for today
is how to migrate windows
workloads to Google Cloud.
And this foundationally
gets back
to Google's principle of meeting
our customers where they are
and helping them migrate
to Google Cloud and a more
open collaborative
architecture for applications
at their own pace,
and in a model that
is more comfortable for them.
Some of that is around
rebuilding your applications,
but a lot of that is also
around lifting and shifting
of your enterprise applications
onto GCP or writing new .NET
Applications.
And that's the
strategy behind making
sure Windows is a Tier I
platform, a first class
platform for running
Windows workloads on GCP.
We have been at it
for a few years now.
We started in 2015 where we
launched our first Windows
Server offerings on GCP.
And since then, we have been
pretty hard at work adding
additional capabilities,
like SQL Server support,
Azure support, various
types of clustering,
and failover support, as
well as toolings around .NET
and PowerShell for making
GCP a great platform for us.
And today, my colleague Simon--
and I'm Souvik.
I'm part of the product
management team,
and Simon is part of
the engineering team.
We are going to spend a
bit of time kind of walking
through the migration journey
for Windows workloads to GCP
and announce a few new products
and offerings that I believe
will be super, super interesting
to many of you in the room.
The first of all, I
just wanted to thank you
for literally tens of thousands
of customers who are running
Windows workflows on GCP.
That may come as a
surprise to a lot of you,
because we have been
kind of creeping along
with ad features, getting
customers along the way.
I can happily say that
the number of customers
who is running Windows
workloads on GCP
is actually really significant.
So if any of you are kind
of hesitant and not sure
if you are going to take the
first step, because there
is not too many customers
on GCP on Windows,
that should definitely
not be a concern anymore.
And the conversation here
more about how to get there
and the details of the
navigation process,
more so than if.
So when we go out and talk
to these tens of thousands
of customers, a representative
of them, like many of you here,
why are they running
Windows on GCP,
a couple of points come
out loud and clear.
So the number one point that
comes out loud and clear
is Google's position
on being open.
We are not a vendor
who wants to lock you
into proprietary technology
or proprietary platform.
We are open.
And I think a lot of
you have this vision
of running your applications
in an open and dynamic cloud,
where you can migrate across
various public cloud platforms
as well as on-premises.
And that's some of
the announcements
that have been made this week.
A second is that
Google did everything.
We have amazing infrastructure,
network security, efficiency,
et cetera, et cetera.
And all of those capabilities
apply to Windows workloads
as well.
We are not going to
touch on them too much,
because this is a pretty big--
Windows is a pretty big topic.
But those play a big role.
The third thing that
we hear is that Windows
is a big part of any enterprise,
data center, or workload.
So as customers move, as you
move many of your workloads,
the Windows
dependency components
need to be supported well.
And that makes up a significant
percentage of the workloads.
And the last one that comes
across pretty frequently also
is the data gravity
and integration
with Google applications.
If many of our customers have
very significant amount of data
on GCP as well as they're
building newer applications
with .NET, .NET Core, and
other languages on GCP,
and if there is a Windows
platform dependency,
running them on GCP just makes
it much more easier, simpler,
secure than running it outside.
So the question then
becomes, how do we get there?
What is the journey?
And having kind of observed this
across many, many customers,
this is kind of
the simple pattern
that we see again and again.
The journey starts
with, hey, I really
don't know what to start.
And they go through
an assessment planning
and a migration phase.
Then they kind of
think about how
do you operate large complex
Windows environments on GCP?
And then they simultaneously
with that or subsequent
to that there's a
phase of, how do
we actually modernize our
Windows applications on GCP?
And we're going to touch on
all of these topics today.
And it's a pretty broad
span of activities.
And we want actually
to demo a few things.
So we would not
necessarily have time
to get into the details of
many of these components.
But there are a number
of individual sessions
that have already happened or
happening in the next two days
to talk about these in details.
So these are some
of the key questions
that we hear from
our customers as they
get started on migrating
their Windows components
or applications to GCP.
The first one is,
how do I start?
The next big thing that
is very Windows specific
is, how does the
licensing thing play out?
Do I have to rebuy all my
Microsoft licenses on GCP?
And lastly, what
exact technologies do
we use for migrating the VMs?
And how do I test and make sure
everything is working together?
And let's touch on
those questions.
But before getting
into the details,
and just given the scope
of the information,
I just wanted to highlight
this migration center website,
which is at
cloud.google.com/migrate.
It's the single place for
accessing all the information
regarding migration.
And you can access it
at any point of time
to get additional information
about our products,
our partners'
products, our service
integrator partners'
products and offerings,
so on and so forth.
So the first phase
of the journey
starts with discovery,
assessment, and planning.
And what we have done here
is that we have closely
partnered with a large
number of ISV vendors,
like Cloud Physics, Stratozone,
Risc Network, Cloudamize,
who have built tools
to discover environment
and helping in the
planning process.
And many of these tools are free
for customers migrating to GCP.
It's not free for everybody.
But what we have done is
structured the agreement
that if you want to
use any of these tools,
just reach out to
us and you can have
pretty much unlimited usage
of many of these tools
as you migrate to GCP for
Windows and other workloads.
And what these tools
does is that it kind of
gets you an understanding
in a very non-intrusive way,
a map of all the applications
running in your data center.
There's a couple
of sample outputs.
Many of these vendors are
there in our show floor.
You can see a demo.
You can also see a demo in
the infrastructure upgrade--
Beverly and in the show floor.
But it kind of
lays out that what
are the critical applications?
What are the dependencies?
If I move this workload,
what other workloads gets
tossed and so on and so forth?
And one other thing that we see
a lot of our customers doing
is trying to identify those
workloads that are not
highly interlinked and not
highly critical to get started.
And then move on to more
and more complex workloads
to migrate to the Cloud.
Ideal examples of
workloads would
include things like test
and dev environments
or pre-production
environments and other things
to kind of try out how
this thing works out.
The other impressive thing
that these ISV vendors
have done working in
close collaboration
with us is that it
actually provides you
very clear [INAUDIBLE] outputs
of how these tools, as you
migrate to the cloud, how
does this thing play out
from a financial perspective?
So you can do a cost
benefit analysis--
doing nothing
versus moving to us.
And while talking about the cost
benefit analysis financials,
one of the biggest things
that are hindering or is
a concern for a lot
of customers migrating
Windows workload to the cloud is
the licensing component of it.
And I just want to spend one
or two minutes just talking
about that in a
little bit of details.
The first thing to remember
is that if you are a Microsoft
Enterprise Agreement
customer, there
are two primary tenets that
applies to license compliance.
Number one is that the licenses
that you bought from Microsoft
using Enterprise
Agreements, they
need to be used in an
infrastructure that
is dedicated to you.
And the next one is even when
you are using, let's say,
Windows Server licenses in
infrastructure that is meant
for you, you cannot move
those licenses around multiple
servers in any time
less than 90 days.
So what that means is that for
many public cloud, the way it
is architected, we
create large pools
of physical infrastructure
and move VMs around.
And a lot of times the
VMs are moved around
even for upgrading the
underlying physical
infrastructure, even
if the certain hosts
are dedicated to you.
So it's not Google specific.
For pretty much all of
the public cloud vendors,
what it means is that you have
to, till now, buy something
called a SPLA license for
running Windows on public cloud
systems.
And SPLA is amazing for
very specific workloads,
like for example, you have
a-- and a SPLA is basically
Windows licenses or
other Microsoft license
you can buy by the second.
So it's very, very good for
very highly spiky usages
where you are using something
for five seconds for hundreds
and hundreds of calls and
don't use it for the year.
It's very advantageous for those
types of workloads to use SPLA.
But on other hand,
if you have already
your basement full
of Windows licenses
or SQL server
licenses, and you don't
want to spend money on
re-buying those licenses--
and they can be costly.
They can be up to 60%
of the price of a VM--
it can become a
prohibitive expense.
So that has been,
historically, a challenge.
But I'm happy to
announce that next we
have announced the beta of
our sole tenant BYOL offering.
And this is really,
really exciting,
because it allows you to
bring your Enterprise License
Agreement into GCP.
So what it basically
means is that you do not
have to spend a huge amount of
dollars buying SPLA licenses.
If you have Enterprise Agreement
Licenses for Windows Server,
SQL Server, you can
dump them on GCP,
run them on the
sole tenant nodes.
And not only do you get
benefit of the licensing,
it also has a lot of the inbuilt
reporting that in case you
get audited by Microsoft, you
can leverage these reports
for compliance purposes.
And we have seen a
huge amount of interest
in the alpha and
the beta customers
we have been working with.
So definitely encourage you
guys to try it out and figure it
out-- dig into this
a little bit more.
And closely associated
with licensing cost,
it's not necessarily
just the BYOL.
The Google Cloud Platform itself
has a large number of primitive
that helps you optimize
licensing and infrastructure
costs.
For example, things like per
second billing, custom VM
sizes, pre-emptible VMs,
right sizing, recommendations
so that you are not using extra
cores, which usually translate
to extra licensing costs.
So altogether it creates a
very significant difference
between what you may have
spent on licensing before
to move to public cloud,
than doing it with us now.
So definitely we
are very excited.
And we expect a lot of customer
adoption and excitement
on that.
Once you have figured out the
licensing and how to migrate,
the next big thing is how do
we actually do that migration.
And I will hand it over
to my colleague Simon
to kind of walk through
a quick demo of the--
SIMON ZELTSER:
Thank you, Souvik.
So with Velostrata, it
actually makes it very,
very easy to migrate your VM
running on-premises the way
to Google Cloud.
When you use Velostrata,
you can basically
take your
applications, which are
up and running with
Windows or with Linux
as well, without installing
anything on the VM,
without changing
your source code,
basically just taking over those
VMs all the way into the cloud.
Now the solution allows
you to do easy testing,
easy rolling back.
If you move the
VMs into the cloud,
and then you decide to move
them back, you can do that too.
Also, if you have
waves of machines,
for example, cluster that
is multiple VMs working
with each other
with dependencies,
you can use the feature called
Run Book Automation which
allows you to move
all those VMs together
such that the dependencies
will be preserved.
I'm going to show
you a small demo.
All right, thank you.
So what we have here is
the vSphere web client.
And I have VMware data
center with multiple VMs--
in this case, two Windows VMs.
What I am doing here in one of
those VMs is running regular
legacy .NET framework
application.
It is hosted on IAS.
And just to show
you what that is,
it's a open source tool called
Orchard for Content Management.
It's currently
running on-premises.
And we'll try to move this
application all the way
into the cloud.
So I'm all ready.
I have all the setup baked in.
So all we need to do is go
into this Velostrata Operations
tab, which you need to install
as part of your vSphere web
client.
And then we have this
option of migrate.
What it does it
opens up a wizard,
which we need to
fill up to say how
is this VM going to be
named once it's ported over
to Google Cloud.
And then what is
the VM configuration
in terms of CPU and RAM?
This storage policy, how are we
going to handle all the writes?
And then the networking,
in this case,
I'm going to create
an ephemeral IP
address so that we can try and
access this VM on Google Cloud
later on.
And then I'm basically
going to run this operation.
Now this operation can take
about 10 minutes to complete.
But what we will
see eventually is
I already have one of
those machines moved,
I moved the win-1 when we just
started this presentation.
So I can show you that
this VM one is actually
accessible through the external
IP address on Google Cloud.
This is the machine.
And all the effort
that I had to do
is just install the VMware
extension for Velostrata,
and also install the server
side part of Velostrata
on my project at Google Cloud.
And then create the
VPN interconnect
between the on-premises
and the cloud.
I did all the setup
ahead of time,
but basically once
you get the setup up
and running, and we have
everything documented
on cloud.google.com, you can
migrate your VMs for free
without changing anything
in the source code,
or even without the VM being
aware of the fact that it's
moving.
Moreover, there is no downtime
that's caused by the fact
that you migrate those VMs.
So it's really powerful
solution that you
can use even today if you
want to migrate your Windows
VMs onto a Google Cloud.
So let's switch back to Souvik.
SOUVIK CHOUDHURY: Thanks Simon.
And that's pretty awesome.
And by the way,
just to highlight,
you can see the GCP
is automatically
recommending how you can
optimize VM sizes to save
certain amount of dollars.
And all of those
numbers are probably
going to be double,
because it's going
to also save Windows
licensing costs as you
go through this phase.
Just wanted to highlight this.
Switch back to the
slides, please.
So the next phase
of the journey,
now that we have landed
your existing VMs on GCP,
is how do we operate and manage
this environment on a day
to day basis?
And over here, some of
the key questions we hear
is how do I deploy new
VMs or apps on GCP?
Is it secure?
How is the performance?
How do I manage my application?
Do I have to do all the stuff
that I was doing in the data
center on GCP, or there's better
way of achieving the same thing
and so on and so forth?
And a couple of points
in that direction.
So once you have migrated,
you may have needs
for new VMs and new
applications to be spun up.
And what you will
see at GCP is that we
have a very, very large library
of pre-engineered, pretested,
pre-optimized Google
Windows images
that you can spin
up whenever you
want with integrated licensing
and all these management tied
into GCP.
In case you can't
find exactly what
application you are looking
for, what you will also find
is a large number of prepackaged
applications as images that are
available in our marketplace.
And the billing, the
licensing, the usage
are all tied to your
overall GCP account.
So it's really, really easy
for you to spin up applications
that you might want
from ISV vendors,
as you can see over here.
I know many of you have much
more strict and stringent
security requirements.
I just wanted to
highlight that all
of these VMs from us
or from a marketplace
can actually be done on
our Shielded VMs, which
makes them even more secure to
run your workloads for Windows
on GCP.
And this is in addition to
all these other great security
features we have
already tied into GCP.
The other thing that I want to
also [INAUDIBLE] highlight over
here is our huge differentiator
from an operational lifetime
perspective, which
is live migration.
So whenever we have to make
infrastructure firmware updates
to our underlying
public cloud platform,
using live migration
technology we
make sure that none of
your workloads get impacted
and there is
continued operation.
So if you're worried
about hey, I'm
going to start running my
Windows applications here,
is it reliable?
Are we going to suffer downtime?
The answer is that you can
be completely confident
that we've got you covered.
We have live migration and
many other technologies
too, which applies for Windows
as well as any other workloads
to provide higher uptime.
So I'm also pleased
to announce a number
of new additional
services as promised.
We are working on the GCP
patch and conflict management.
The purpose of this
is to make sure
that when you are running all
these Windows VMs, as well
as Linux and other
VMs, you do not
have to manually keep on
patching and extending your
on prem applications to GCP.
This is a very simple click
through console integrated
into the GCP console, which
allows you to understand how
many of your VMs
that are running
are at a certain batch
level [INAUDIBLE]
level, based on risk practices.
And if they are
not at par, you can
set policies to either upgrade
them or take additional steps.
You can also drive policy
saying that all the VMs running
in this projects needs to
have these configurations,
because that's what you
mandate, that's what is secure,
and that's how you kind
of enforce standardization
across your fleet of VMs.
If we detect any of these VMs do
not comply with these policies,
you can trigger actions,
including highlighting them
in a report and other things,
so that it makes it much, much
easier for you to manage these
large fleets of VMs right
from the console without
having to use third party tools
or extending on prem tools.
And we are looking for alpha
partners to test this out.
We expect to get
this out sometime
before the end of the year.
And my colleague, Ravi, here--
just feel free to stop by and
ask him for additional details.
We're also very, very excited
to announce our managed SQL
offering on GCP.
So we already had a large number
of standardized SQL images
that are optimized for
GCP you could spin up.
But one of the things
that we heard repeatedly
from our customers is, hey,
I have a 1,000, 2,000, 3,000
instances of SQL.
I really don't want to manage
that once they're on GCP.
You guys should be
doing more of that
so that I can focus
more of my efforts
on higher order business
value generating problems.
And that's what we have.
So you can actually
spin up these SQL VMs
and we will manage them
for you under an SLA.
It's fully compliant to
Microsoft Work environments
and takes another load off you.
Very similar to SQL, AD is
another integral part of GCP.
And we already had AD service.
But we are happy to
[INAUDIBLE] the beta or coming
soon for the beta for
the Managed AD service.
And I will hand it over
to my partner Simon
again, to kind of walk through
that and show you a quick demo.
SIMON ZELTSER: Thank you Souvik.
So with Managed Service for
Microsoft Active Directory,
what you get is Microsoft
Active Directory,
but hardened and
managed by Google.
You get the system
configuration, patching,
replication, all
of those hassles
that you typically need to
deal with when you manage
Active Directory yourself, you
get that all offset and taken
care of by a Google Operations
team and our service
that we just announced recently.
And the beta of Microsoft Active
Directory Managed by Google
is going to be announced
very, very soon.
So look out for that.
If you want to join the alpha
and express more interest,
there is a link on the slides
that you can join and get
some more details.
You can extend your
existing Active Directory
from on-premises all
the way to Google Cloud,
and manage their identities
in a unified way using
this offering.
I want to show you a
small demo of that.
What you see here is
our cloud console.
And on the Security tab
there is a new option
called Managed Microsoft AD.
This is where we can create your
own Microsoft Active Directory
Domain.
So all I need to do just going
into the Create AD Domain
and add some name, networking
settings, and which region I
want to deploy this
Active Directory setup.
And then I can also
name the admin user.
This admin user
is what you get so
that you can manage all your
identities using that user.
You can also delegate starting
from this user to other users
that you might create.
Basically you can use the
same familiar Active Directory
tools like Active Directory
Users and Computers
to manage all your
Active Directory needs.
But this user is going to be
your gateway into the Managed
Active Directory.
And you will get full control
of all the user's computers
and other Active Directory
objects that you might create.
Once I hit Create here, it's
going to take about 40 minutes
to create.
So I already have a
few domains out there.
Once I create this
domain, you can be sure
that it's all managed by Google.
There are multiple domain
controller instances
that we spin up so that
it's good for redundancy
and for overall health of
your Active Directory setup.
SOUVIK CHOUDHURY:
Thank you, Simon.
So now that we have
covered the assess,
plan, and migrate, and operate,
let's talk a little bit
about modernization,
because that's, I believe,
where all of us wants
to be, just a question
of when and how.
So for modernizing Windows
applications on GCP or .NET
applications and GCP--
so we provide a
number of instruments.
We provide containers on
GCP that kind of helps
you streamline the operations.
And there have been multiple
sessions around that at Next.
We provide .
NET Client libraries
for all GCP APIs.
So if you are a .NET developer
or your clients are .NET
developers, you can rest assured
that even if they can build
in a language that
they're comfortable with,
and run those applications
seamlessly on GCP,
and in a lot of cases, even
if they're not running on GCP,
you can still access these
APIs from on-premises or other
clouds.
It's tightly integrated
with the Visual Studio.
So once again, making sure
that the developer experience
is seamless as they migrate from
other cloud platforms to GCP.
And the last one is we have
invested a lot in making sure
our Stackdriver technologies
are integrated into the .NET
Platform.
So you have much more
visibility into what's going on
and what's working, which
is working not on GCP.
Now, let's talk about how--
so at the same-- now we're
really excited to announce is
the availability of--
the coming soon, as
we are working really,
really closely with Microsoft
on Windows Server Container
Support in GKE.
We are really
excited, because this
allows you to provide
a seamless operating
experience across Linux and
Windows containers on GCP
and really optimize
your operations.
And my colleague,
[INAUDIBLE] here,
will be around to answer any
questions after the session.
So now that we have talked
about all these instruments
that we have at
our disposal, let's
talk about how you
kind of use all of them
to modernize your applications.
So the first and
the easiest case
is probably new or existing
apps that can be rewritten
or you want to rewrite for GCP.
And over here you
have GCP, .NET, APIs,
various types of
tools we talked about,
like the VisualStudio
integration
and the Stackdriver, to rewrite
those applications and run that
on App Engine, which is
entirely cloud native.
You don't have to manage it.
You don't have to
think about it.
It kind of
[INAUDIBLE] magically.
But we also know
that that's probably
going to be a small percentage
of the overall application
that you manage.
So what do you do with them?
So there are going to be some
applications that you are going
to be running on .NET that
can be converted to .NET Core
applications.
And we understand that .NET
Core is not really as expansive
as to write all applications.
But a certain set of
applications you can migrate.
And what you can do is
that as you re-architect
your applications to .NET Core,
you can actually run .NET Core
on a Linux on a GKE server.
So what happens is your overall
operating platform is now much
more open, because .NET
Core can learn on Linux,
and it's moving more and
more towards open source.
Now there are going to be a
set of applications where you
can't convert to .NET.
This may be traditional
.NET applications,
maybe even Windows
32 applications.
What you can do there is
convert them to GKE containers,
and run them on a manage
GKE service on Windows.
So what happens is that
it's not completely open.
It's not completely scalable.
You still have a
Windows footprint there,
but you have
actually taken a lot
of the pain out of the customer
environment of the platform
by making it part of the
overall GKE solution.
And finally, there are going
to be Windows applications that
can't even be containerized.
Maybe they're really old or have
some special quirks that stops
it from being containerized.
And for those applications,
you can still move them to GCP,
like we talked about.
And you still get
all the benefits
of managed services, licensing,
things like managed instance
groups that makes it easier for
you to scale up and scale down
the resource usage,
and so on and so forth.
And hopefully, you know,
initially when you start,
most of the application
that you have
are going to be the
bottom part of the slide.
But as time goes by, you kind
of start moving your apps
more and more up the stack.
And at some point
of time, you're
in a much more free and open
world than you are right now.
So that's how this
thing hangs together.
And I would hand over to my
colleague for this final time
to kind of show a demo of how
all these things work together.
SIMON ZELTSER:
Thank you, Souvik.
So can I switch back please?
All right.
Thank you.
So we are going to see a demo
how some of the tools that
Souvik mentioned earlier for
modernization are playing
together when you develop your
.NET or .NET Core application.
In order to understand
the demo, we
thought that it's
going to be very
useful to see the
storyboard first,
and then we actually
will go through the demo.
So at first, we'll
see application,
which is quite typical once
you start modernizing your .NET
framework to .NET Core.
And this is the application
with three layers.
You have front end talking to a
back end talking to a database.
All those are microservices
that run on Kubernetes
cluster on a managed GKE.
And there is a problem there.
In order to understand
and diagnose the problem,
we'll use tools such as
Stackdriver Debugger with
Logpoint Support for .NET Core.
And we'll try to
spot the problem.
We'll then make an update into
the code using the tool that we
are happy to announce today
called Cloud Code for Visual
Studio Code with
.NET Core Support.
And then after the deployment
using that tool is complete,
we'll see that the application
is all up and running again
on Google Cloud.
So now let's please
switch back to my laptop.
What you see here is the
Guestbook application
that I just mentioned earlier.
So you can type some text.
And then you should be
able to post this text
into the Guestbook, which
would store it eventually
in some database.
But it takes some time, and
apparently doesn't work.
So probably it happened
to some of you in the past
that it works on my
machine, but when
I move it to a
different environment,
it stops working
for some reason.
So the problem might
be not necessarily
relevant to the code,
but more so relevant
to the changes between
different environments.
And so we want to understand
what the problem is.
So I open the tool called
Stackdriver Debugger.
Stackdriver Debugger
is a tool that
allows you to troubleshoot
applications live in production
doing what we call
snapshot debugging,
as well as attaching logpoints.
I'll talk more about the
logpoints experience.
With logpoints, you can add
additional logging statement
in already running application
without changing its source
code, but with adding
more context for you
to troubleshoot the problem.
What we'll do here is adding
a statement on line 46--
this is the code
of the application
that you saw earlier--
I am adding a logpoint.
I can make it conditional,
but I'll, just for simplicity,
will add it with an
always true statement.
And I am going to write
backendAddr equals--
basically, there is a
variable on line 46.
It's sending a
request to a back end,
but I don't know what
back end address is that.
So for that, I'll try to
print that value into the log.
So once we do that, we
basically added a logpoint
without changing a code.
The way it works
is that we, which
is Stackdriver in this
case, react to callback.
So once the code
password we added
the logpoint is
being hit, there will
be a callback that will send
the log message that we just
added into Stackdriver
Logger so that you will
be able to see this additional
log statement that wasn't there
before when you actually
deployed the application
in the first place.
This allows you to
troubleshoot applications
without the need to redeploy
by adding more log statements.
It could be very useful,
because sometimes deployment
could be a stressful operation.
Also with some of the safe
deployment practices out there,
it might take some time to
actually roll out the changes
that you're making
into your application.
So this could become very handy.
So let's try to execute
this application again.
And so by refreshing
this page, I'm
actually trying to
execute the same code path
where we added the logpoint.
And so now if we
refresh, we should
see that it actually
added this log statement,
backendAddr equals.
And this is the actual
value of the variable,
which wasn't known before.
So you can see here that
there is a typo in back end.
And this is likely why the
application is not working.
Now I want to deploy
a change which
will fix this application.
So for that I will use
a tool called Cloud Code
for Visual Studio Code.
This is a new extension that we
are pleased to announce today.
It supports four programming
languages out of the box.
And .NET Core is the fifth
language that we add to that.
With this extension, you can
browse your Kubernetes cluster
objects, see what ports and
deployments and other objects
you have, you can
connect to specific ports
for troubleshooting.
You can get more details about
what's currently deployed
and where without memorizing all
the QCTL commands for managing
and working with
Kubernetes clusters.
So it really streamlines
the inner and outer loop
of your development experience.
So let's make a change here,
and change buckend into backend.
And then I want to deploy it.
In order to deploy,
all I need to do
is starting a new command,
which is Cloud Code Deploy.
What this will
do, it will ask me
what profile do I want to use.
So this extension supports
multiple profiles.
And you can think about profiles
as different environments
that you might have
in your application.
So maybe I want to deploy
to my local machine
and see if it works,
but I can also
choose a different environment.
In my case, I choose to actually
deploy it into Google Cloud.
And what happens
now as I speak is
that the application is
packaging all my code,
pushing it into GCS bucket.
And then we are going
to invoke a tool
called Cloud Build,
which will try
to build all of the
code of my application,
create a container image,
and then push that container
image into my cluster.
All of that is going to happen
completely automatically
without you needing to deal
with all of the small pieces
of how do I build?
How do I debug?
And how do I deploy?
It's all taken care
of by this tool.
Now the deployment by itself
can take a few minutes here,
so we'll just let it run.
But what I wanted
to show is basically
how handy this tool can
become in your inner loop
when you try to develop
your application
and repeatedly debug
and deploy them all
the way into the cloud.
So to just sum up
what we saw today,
we actually can develop
applications using .NET
framework, move them all
the way to Google Cloud with
Velostrata.
And then if we
want to modernize,
we can move to .NET Core, use
any of Google Cloud's public
APIs using .NET
client libraries,
and then use tools such as
Stackdriver Debugger with
Logpoint Support and Visual
Studio Code Extension Called
Cloud Code with .NET Core
support to be able to build,
debug, and deploy your
modernized application
on Google Cloud.
OK, so that's all I have.
And I'd like to hand
over back to Souvik.
SOUVIK CHOUDHURY:
Thank you, Simon.
[APPLAUSE]
So first, once again, thanking
you guys for your trust--
many, many of our
customers and many of you
for trusting your Windows
workloads to be done on GCP.
And as you can see
just this week,
there are six
major announcements
on Windows platform
where we are going
to make it much more robust,
easier to manage, easier
to scale on GCP.
The beta for Sole tenant BYOL,
massive for traditional Windows
workloads from a
licensing perspective,
customer perspective, beta
of the Managed AD Service
pre-beta, once again,
critical Windows workload.
We want to make it easier
for you to deploy and manage.
Alpha for Managed SQL, Batch
and Conflict Management Service,
Windows for GKE, and .NET
Core support for Cloud Code
for Visual Studio.
And again, as you can
see, we have trying
and we have executed
on and giving you
everything you need from
migrating, operating,
and modernizing
your applications.
And this is just the start.
And many more exciting
things are going to come.
And those are all
going to add on
to make us a better
and better platform
to modernize your applications.
So these are some other sessions
that will be of interest.
Some of them actually
has happened,
but you can find their
recordings on YouTube
and many other platforms.
And we'll really
appreciate your feedback.
[MUSIC PLAYING]